un français sur dix prend des vacances
d'hiver à la montagne et ce chiffre va
en augmentant
malgré la crise et pourquoi il nous a
semblé intéressant de visiter pour vous
si vous ne pouvez le faire
le salon mais j'ai montagne qui se tient
à paris à la porte de versailles
jusqu'au 29 octobre
on peut y voir les dernières nouveautés
en matière de matériel et de mode et
l'on peut même déjà y faire une bataille
de boules de neige enquête d'alan b
style à des aléas nouveautés du salon en
matière de chaussures de ski du cuir
cousu main entièrement doublé c'était
bien sûr un salon vieux d'une
quarantaine d'années le dernier cri le
voici deux avantages
premièrement on n'a plus besoin de la
cire et deuxièmement et surtout on la
chose par l'arrière c'est plus
confortable plus rapide
un seul crochet au lieu de trois ou
quatre c'est l'avenir nous at on dit les
fixations
si je vous dis que c'est la nouveauté
vous ne me croirez plus alors passons
passons à look et salomon les deux
leaders mondiaux dans ce domaine
ils sont français en matière de fixation
pas de révolution cette année
le capteur de force chez l'un pas
vraiment indispensable chez l'autre le
design et le chaussage du talon arrière
améliorer c'est tout une nouveauté mais
seuls les très bons scores
l'apprécieront le bâton coup d il
améliore la position avancée surtout
pour le slalom pour les amateurs de
balades à ce qui par contre cette
fixation supplémentaire qui leur
permettra de passer instantanément de la
position ski alpin à la position ski de
fond intéressant par exemple pour
rejoindre une piste en passant par un
chemin de forêt enfin le ski lui même un
demi siècle de progrès ininterrompue
depuis les planches en bois de nos
grands-pères rossignol lacroix dynamique
dynastar pour ne parler que des français
proposent tous deux légères
transformations mais la grande tendance
pour toutes ses marques
c'est l'amélioration de la vitesse du
ski les matériaux restent inchangés
kevlar carbone fibre de verre on avait
déjà travaillé la souplesse cette année
on a amélioré la glisse en augmentant
par pression la densité des matériaux
utilisés
le vêtement maintenant dans les magasins
spécialisés comme pour le matériel
vous trouverez des tendances et des
matériaux nous
le blouson rouge portée par cette jeune
femme est en toile de bâche tu déjà vu
mais ça revient parait-il par contre les
tissus des vêtements qu'elle choisit son
nouveau oublié les mots serge gabardine
popeline par exemple retenez plutôt
freestyle spinnaker free ce cas ils ont
des aspects nouveaux plus fin mais
imperméabilisées il brille ils sont
pucées ou d'aspect froissé naturellement
retenez le motive ac également c'est une
nouvelle doublure grâce à laquelle vous
ne ressemblerait plus à un nounours plus
fine mais aussi chaude aussi confortable
que le duvet pendant que j'y suis je
vais faire un petit tour sur les
plates-bandes de ma consoeur chargé de
la mode pour vous dire que j'aime
beaucoup les superpositions qui
permettent d'adapter les vêtements à la
température et surpiqûres les fermetures
éclair pardon les zips et puis les
couleurs pourquoi s'en priver tout cela
bien sûr coûte cher alors pour ne pas
vous sentir trop frustré gardez votre
blouson de l'an dernier mais achetez
vous un de ces jolies bonnet turban
cagoule et puis finalement c'est bien
utile quand même